[Música]
Ecuador vota este domingo para elegir a
las autoridades locales pero la atención
se centra en el referendo constitucional
que propone el gobierno de Guillermo
lasso y que la oposición considera un
riesgo para la democracia
miles de personas marcharon este sábado
por las calles de Lima la capital de
Perú en una nueva jornada de
manifestaciones antigubernamentales y
por el adelanto de las elecciones
pidieron también justicia para al menos
59 muertos en choques con las fuerzas de
seguridad desde diciembre nuestro
corresponsal habló con algunos
manifestantes
la armada brasileña hundió en el
Atlántico un antiguo portaaviones
francés de los años 50 una opción
Inevitable según la Marina un crimen
medioambiental para varias ong
ecologistas por los residuos tóxicos que
aún contienen su interior
Bienvenidos a Nueva informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos abrimos este Informativo en
Ecuador porque este domingo los
ciudadanos eligen a las autoridades
locales pero también decidirán si
aprueban ocho reformas a la Constitución
que el gobierno de Guillermo lasso
propone y que han generado dudas
críticas en la oposición por considerar
que representan un riesgo para la
democracia pero que el mandatario
Argumenta son necesarias para controlar
la inseguridad Samuel Salgado nos tiene
los detalles
elecciones y un polémico referendo cerca
de 13 millones de Ecuatorianos elegirán
5.660 autoridades locales las campañas
culminaron el 2 de febrero el
oficialismo trató de desmarcarse el
presidente Guillermo lasso quien ha
visto su popularidad afectada por
escándalos recientes de corrupción en su
familia el debate no se centró en los
candidatos sino en ocho reformas
constitucionales que lazos somete a
referendo y que la oposición ha señalado
que representan un riesgo para la
democracia la reforma constitucional
Busca reducir el número de asambleístas
controlar el número de afiliados a los
movimientos políticos a través del
Consejo Nacional electoral y aumentar la
autonomía de la fiscalía general la
designación del fiscal pasaría a manos
de la asamblea nacional esta también
seleccionaría a los miembros del Consejo
de participación ciudadana organismo de
control creado en 2008 que elige al
procurador general otra enmienda Busca
la extradición de han cometido delitos
relacionados con el crimen organizado
transnacional como el narcotráfico
tráfico de armas y la trata de personas
desde la oposición la confederación de
nacionalidades indígenas compuesta por
14 pueblos originarios anunció que no
apoyara ninguna reforma el 18 de
noviembre la conaie decidió trabajar en
la consulta popular todo por el no el
gobierno se mantiene firme y defiende
como uno de los ejes de sus propuestas
la lucha contra el crimen organizado
creo que además manda un mensaje
comunicacional importante y que los
Ecuatorianos estamos dispuestos a
decirle sí a un ecuador más seguro menos
politiquería y también más cuidadoso con
el medio ambiente los Ecuatorianos
también votarán sobre la creación de un
subsistema de protección
hídrica al Sistema Nacional de áreas
protegidas y compensaciones para los
ciudadanos que cuiden el ambiente
Vamos hasta Perú donde los manifestantes
avanzaron en Lima en una nueva jornada
de manifestaciones antigubernamentales y
por el adelanto de las elecciones miles
de personas marcharon para pedir además
justicia para los al menos 59 muertos en
choques con las fuerzas de seguridad
desde diciembre la mayoría de los
manifestantes son indígenas que llegaron
a la capital tras caminar miles de
kilómetros desde las regiones nuestro
corresponsal en Lima Francisco Zacarías
estuvo con ellos y no es preparó el
siguiente informe
Juan mamani dejó de cultivar el campo a
sus 60 años recorrió 982 kilómetros
desde copani su pueblo natal para
protestar no nos dejaron marchar
tranquilamente nos provocan no con
infiltrados ellos son los primeros
asesinos nosotros venimos a ser
pacíficamente nuestra lucha nuestra
lucha es justa
esta lucha tiene que ser hasta último
Hasta quemar el último cartucho Aún es
el reinicio de las protestas alrededor
de 60 peruanos han muerto y más de 1500
resultaron heridos debido a la represión
del gobierno de Dina boluarte según
denuncias de organismos de Derechos
Humanos
pese estas cifras la lucha permanece en
Lima los indígenas duermen donde pueden
y se las ingenia para alimentarse con lo
que encuentran los manifestantes han
amenazado con recrudecer la protesta
porque el congreso rechazó el adelanto
de elecciones hay intenciones de tomar
el congreso hay intenciones
de tomar instituciones públicas como
fiscalía
es ministerio público poder judicial
otras instituciones más donde campea la
corrupción al no aprobar el parlamento
el adelanto electoral el descontento
social ha crecido en contra de Dina
boluarte y al oler esa debilidad lo que
van a hacer es en lugar de replegarse
van a avanzar porque se van a dar cuenta
que Dina boluarte y el congreso no tiene
ni capacidad ni intención de resolver el
problema frente a eso yo creo que las
marchas van a continuar los bloqueos van
a continuar la violencia Va a continuar
Lamentablemente y ahí lo único que le va
a quedar al gobierno será seguir
reprimiendo con el saldo lamentable que
pueda venir adelante los manifestantes
inspiran su lucha en los ancestrales
incas afirman que no se rendirán hasta
conquistar sus demandas sin importar que
en el intento quizás puedan perder sus
vidas
el Antiguo portaaviones francés
construido a finales de los años 50 fue
hundido en el Océano Atlántico por la
marina brasileña según el organismo no
había otra opción dado el mal estado del
barco para varias ongs sin embargo
algunas de ellas ecologistas se trata de
un crimen medioambiental por los
residuos tóxicos que aún se encuentran
dentro del buque
un antiguo buque insignia de la marina
francesa ahora ya será aquí en el fondo
del Océano Atlántico las autoridades
brasileñas hundieron el Antiguo
portaaviones Fox que llevaba meses en el
mar a 300 kilómetros de la costa
brasileña lleno de asbesto pintura y
otros residuos tóxicos se considera una
bomba ecológica múltiples ongs han
considerado su hundimiento como un
crimen medioambiental por su tamaño 266
metros Y su peso 30,000 toneladas su
reciclaje era impensable según el
Ministerio de defensa brasileño en vista
de los riesgos que significa el remolque
y debido al deterioro del casco la única
solución es abandonarlo hundiéndolo de
forma controlada
el portaaviones fue comprado por Brasil
en el 2000 pero el país decidió
rápidamente deshacerse de él debido a su
obsolencia construido a finales de los
50 El Force rebotizado Sao Paulo estuvo
al servicio de la marina francesa
durante 37 años
participó entre otras en pruebas
nucleares en el Pacífico y en
operaciones en la antigua juveslavia
entre 1993 y 1999
el departamento de defensa de Estados
Unidos derribó El Globo chino al que
señala de espionaje frente a las costas
del este del país por su parte china
tildó el hecho de reacción excesiva y
dejó que se guarda el derecho a
responder y sostiene que el globo no
servía para llevar a cabo escuchas
ilegales el pentágono también denunció
la presencia de un segundo globo chino
en los cielos de latinoamérica la fuerza
aérea colombiana informó que el 3 de
febrero un objeto con características
similares a un globo sobrevoló el
espacio aéreo del país sin representar
una amenaza a la seguridad nacional
en Chile los incendios en el centro del
país han dejado al menos 23 muertos el
fuego ha sido generado por las altas
temperaturas en medio de una ola de
calor Alba Santana tiene a los detalles
entre llamas así se encuentra el centro
sur de chile donde hay más de 250 focos
de incendios 80 de ellos en activo que
ya han arrasado miles de hectáreas han
dañado más de un centenar de viviendas y
han dejado varios amuertos entre ellos
miembros del equipo de bomberos y
civiles son personas que se desplazaban
por caminos en un caso un camino
principal en otro caso un camino
interior se desplazaban en vehículos en
un caso se calcinaron porque fueron
alcanzados por el fuego en el otro
sufrieron un accidente probablemente
tratando de escapar del fuego los
incendios se concentran en las regiones
de ñuble y biobío que están bajo estado
de excepción por catástrofe y también en
maule y la araucanía de momento no hay
previsión de que los incendios vayan a
extinguirse a pesar de que los bomberos
han conseguido controlar al menos 150
focos una situación que obligó al
presidente Gabriel borich a cancelar sus
vacaciones y trasladarse a la zona
estamos con ustedes que la fuerza del
Estado va a estar desplegada primero
para combatir los incendios y para
acompañar a todas las víctimas las
alertas rojas y las órdenes de
evacuación han obligado a muchos a
buscar refugios en albergues ya que las
llamas han dejado a muchos sin casa y
han forzado la evacuación de municipios
enteros terrible porque esfuerzo de año
de mi hermano del 2017 que no veíamos
algo así
un vecinos los vecinos están sacando
pocos cosas y uno y llega la ayuda pero
uno ve que parece que no fuera
suficiente lo único que quiere que
llegue agua que el helicóptero que
llegue luego de conaf que llegue todo el
mundo si está en medio de una ola de
calor principal causa de los incendios
en los últimos días las temperaturas en
la zona han rozado los 40 grados celsius
y se esperan a fuertes vientos que
podrían empeorar las conflagraciones
hasta aquí las noticias sigan conectadas
[Música]